this is the time of year when goodwill
is abundant and a fair share of it is
coming from one historic ranch in
colorado that's where every christmas
tree that is cut down is benefiting
women in need and is benefiting the land
too on top of that the ranch itself is
about to become an important refuge for
veterans and their families from
colorado barry peterson has the story
there she goes beautiful
the roar of a chainsaw is the sound of
christmas in the rockies
where people gathered at the aspen
canyon ranch to choose a tree
paying with a donation to denver's
dolores project which gives shelter to
women experiencing homelessness
wanted table top size
it's perfect
marky and don mosley wanted big and tall
hunting deep into the forest
yeah
ready for me to cut it
yeah look at it from all sides
yeah that looks perfect sawing it down
was easy
but getting it out was a struggle
through the underbrush stick with fallen
trees and dead vegetation yeah i think
it'll be perfect why
it's the perfect shape and the ornaments
will hang nicely on it which is why this
christmas tree outing has a purpose the
more trees they cut the better
because it helps prevent this
simply put a forest with more trees and
more underbrush means more fuel feeding
more raging fires fuel reduction means
you cut the trees down right and got the
undergrowth out yes ryan mcnurtney is a
forester for the colorado state forest
service who developed a multi-year plan
for this ranch
why have you done that in terms of
forest fire mitigation so
the the trees here on on our left is
very dense
and overgrown and then because of that
there's a ton of fuel in there that is
available to be burned whereas on the
other side we've we've done a management
activity over here that has really taken
out a lot of the trees spaced them out
by removing
some trees we're giving the other trees
more space to grow and an ability to
prevent prevent themselves from being
burned up
to get the trees out a machine literally
chops them up
or workers cut and stack debris on
hillsides into what are called teepees
ready for controlled burns this was once
a dude ranch then a pot smokers b and b
when all that failed its rustic cabins
were left to decay
philip sevier took over and now the
cabins are headed for nearby towns they
look a little
worn now but they're going to be
refurbished and they'll be homes yeah
they'll be redone yeah you're recycling
the log cabins of colorado absolutely
yeah
the fire prevention plan makes the ranch
more valuable and sevier has gotten big
box offers he said no
instead he will sell it to a group
called project sanctuary that brings
military families together to reconnect
after long deployments
if you give it to a rich guy they're
going to put a big fence around it and
close it off you sell it to an
organization
there's going to be hundreds of people
affected positively because of this
experience the family fishing on the
river hanging out hiking we have
beautiful lakes
and will help heal it will it will the
mosley's tree has gone from its forest
home
to their home what are the kids and
especially the grandkids learn about
this
real tree that you have and you decorate
it well it's from the forest
um
they see little trees when they go
hiking and they touch the tops and they
say that i've touched the top of this
tree and they know it'll grow big marley
sees it through the delighted eyes of a
five-year-old
what's your favorite part of the
christmas tree
why
because they look like sparkles and
three-year-old monty is a forest fire
fighting tree trimmer in the making what
do you want for christmas
a lego dragon okay what do you want for
christmas uh a chainsaw what do you do
with the chainsaw man
and with fewer trees left the better
chance the rest will survive and just
maybe become next year's point of
christmas joy
for cbs saturday morning barry peterson
in the rocky mountains